what's good what's good what's good good
morning everybody
good morning good morning July 7th in
the building big day
here we are team Carey be glad to be
back last week was fire let's see if we
can keep that momentum going let me get
some shout out to everybody in the
comments are we all part of this share
squad let's definitely like take the
URLs
let's hit the share button across all
the platforms let's share share share
share share share sister share key
Jordan what's good la PA what's good
Yami Soto thank you for joining us Ted
parmesan was good Kelly Hill on Facebook
is in the building check for Katie
Connor gray what's good Jake ward on
LinkedIn is in the building voiceover
Donnie on periscope is in the building
hey Dave a on LinkedIn where's the
twitch family where's the twitch name
there's it's which family soos good to
see what up
I'm Willie D in the building I love
Willie D ro Heath great to see sandy s
good to see you Elijah loose in the
building morning morning morning morning
morning
Dustin hope you're doing well share
share share share share share share
let's get that going Dustin I'm sure
you're working behind the scenes maybe
that's why you're not pumping in but no
you said hi so is like okay I want you
in the mix oh thank you Lauren you are
the star of tea with Gary B Matt buy any
sports cards in the last week pokemon
let's go I think they paid a little too
much but I don't won't you won't end up
paying too much that market is I know
like I've been doing research and I was
like damn only two months ago is like
half the price it is now every fog
everything every basketball soccer in
Pokemon a wrestling card was a half the
price
two months ago it's just yeah
see how hot it is yeah all right let's
get in the show cool yo Dee what's good
man what's good Jesse how are you great
man good morning good morning good
morning well I can't
awesome awesome so I just want to say um
thank you for everything honestly um we
watch your show for years at this point
I don't know if you remember me but we
have met at complex con LA I recall yeah
I was waiting in line they were like you
got to buy the shoes and I was like I
didn't come to buy a sheet I came about
talk to Gary I know he'll talk to me so
appreciate that for sure um so I just
want to tell you a little bit about
myself a little bit of context what I do
um I told you my company before is jokes
LLC um basically our mission is to
inspire and it's still confidence and
those who have been laughed at
misunderstood overlooked by the hands of
normality through design art and fashion
so well how I got to the name jokes so I
was a dancer for eight years hip hop
dance main inspiration um kind of did
that for a while went to college Temple
University joined a dance team my goal
was to open up a non-profit dance
organization for kids and I blew out my
knee so this is the third time I blew
out my knee and I was just like dance
has always been something freeing for me
you know and then it became something of
fear you know yeah good time I danced
I'm gonna I'm gonna bust my knee yeah of
course you know so I had to find
something to focus my creativity you
know and I started painting so I've
always been like artistic um and I took
that painting and the name jokes comes
from my dance name so my dad's name was
joke star and I took that when I was
like 16 and started to brand it so I
turned joke star into an animal so what
that meant was um an individual who
despite being criticized or made fun of
who sticks to their goals and eventually
shines got a mock appeal was I was gonna
turn kids from jokes to stars by
teaching them confidence through dance
because that's what they gave me I love
that thank you thank you I appreciate it
and that whole entire thing switched my
I stopped dancing
so I kind of lost myself lost the
mission and
I found painting and at the time I was
calling my paintings jokes art I was
just doing it cuz it was already my
branding name and then what had happened
was I started putting my paintings on
t-shirts and then it clicked and it was
literally joke's on me and I was like
wow and then it was like joke's on us so
when you wear its joke's on you when I
wears joke's on me when we wear jokes on
us so I took my name I got the LLC jokes
LLC and I was like all right I got a
fashion brain now with the joke's on us
and I'm still doing the art with the
jokes are gathered so it's kind of like
the parent company's jokes just a whole
lot of [ __ ] jokes it's a whole lot of
jokes because at the end of the day what
I'm trying to do is let everybody know
that ultimately the joke's on us you
know it's a confidence thing everybody
gets made fun of everybody gets pushed
around course what are you gonna do
about it you know so when you wear this
when you wear this brand when you see
the jokes when you see the name I
basically want that to mean confidence
you know I want it to be where if
someone's wearing Gucci or someone's
wearing easy it's like it doesn't matter
what they're wearing you know because
the joke's on us like it's all over us
completely you've completely established
it I got it go ahead so what can I
answer so basically um my goal is I'm
trying to get jokes on the world and I'm
not really I feel like being a true
artist
I don't it's hard for me to conform to
the social media the Instagram the white
boxes the posting and I feel like I'm
trying to create art to fit in these
boxes you know and it's not working out
for me very well well and and so you're
trying to figure out how to translate
the mission and the message and the
content onto social well that that's
part of it I think I'm doing pretty good
at getting the message out but I think
the trouble I have is just focusing on
the social you know I kind of want to
just go in all in on the art and to give
a little bit more context like I was a
business major in college I want for
insurance so I have a day job and
insurance I do all this on that back end
but it's hard for me to balance the
business
and our you know so if I kind of like
I'm having troubles with that and I kind
of just want to go full fledge with the
art but I have this job I have student
loan debt and all that stuff so well I
mean there's a lot of variables here one
no different than if I was a dancer
that'd be a big [ __ ] disaster
are you actually capable of building a
business is number one are you something
that you have to figure out to your in
the practical part of your life right
now unfortunately have these student
loans so you've got to have this job you
know there's a couple ways to play it
one you go all-in on the art and
business potentially even with a
business partner who might be better at
business than you and and do that for a
year give yourself a year give yourself
two years and if it doesn't work out
then you go you keep collecting interest
on that debt and then you go back to
practicality but you always felt like
you went for it or you go the other
route and kind of eat some more [ __ ] for
another three four years do the on the
side I think the biggest thing that
stands out for me is are you actually
you know it's fun that you're such a
talent in art and dance because it
because you then recognize that other
people can't you know how you and your
boys and girls made fun of other people
for not being able to dance you know
that's kind of how I do it with business
like you know like you know you just
and when I say make fun of you're not
doing jokes you're recognizing oh [ __ ]
this is talent and I think JC the
biggest thing you need to figure out is
are you actually capable are you
actually capable of running a business
that's gonna you have people buy art buy
clothes do things and and the reality is
oftentimes even on this show we can be
around the bush kind of skirting the
issue which is a lot of people just
don't know how to build businesses my
business history um
so I started a long I started
landscaping business when I was 13 me
and my home he went around all did all
that stuff I worked at Subway when I was
16 and after that was like a janitor you
have you have work ethic yeah like
nobody [ __ ] tries harder than me
playing basketball right the problem is
I couldn't play on a high school
basketball team let alone a professional
one I think it's very clear to me and I
can even see in your conviction
than even your rebuttal here that I
think you have the work ethic the
question is do you have the talent to
sell enough paintings and hoodies and
t-shirts to make that a sustainable
living that is something you have to
really ask yourself and if the answer is
no if you're being really robbed then
you go and get a business partner if the
answer is yes then you make the decision
of one of two moves you jump out of
insurance and you go full throttle for
24 months on this get really [ __ ] raw
you you know spend money on nothing but
like food and shelter collect even more
debt because you're compounding your
interest you're not doing the you're not
doing payments because you're going all
in on the art thing and you go two years
on that and then if it doesn't work you
go back and you feel great that you
tried or you go the other route next two
years you [ __ ] save every dollar
don't spend anything start paying off
that debt and then jump full throttle in
two or three years or four years and go
for it that's just the decision you have
to make for yourself gotcha I think
where I'm at right now is home so the
business has been doing pretty well um I
have products worldwide I just got my
orders in Denmark how much how much tell
the truth here how much top-line revenue
for the year is the business doing so
sales for the year those for the year I
have I have to like double look into
that but roughly been at LSE for three
years I've been doing the online
business for three years first year we
did about a grand um very minimal you
know just friends in him yeah second
year was like 3,500 and this year we
just broke 10 K so it's wrong that's in
sales and then with profit it's gonna be
much lower all of which is not
sustainable for you to live on and I
think I think again I think the question
is it's a three-prong attack for you do
you need a business partner yeah who's
really got it she or he in business and
if not and you feel like you're doing
10k because you have so little time on
it but if you go full throttle you can
get it to 100k then you got to decide
there you can do that now and get deeper
in debt or are you gonna do that in
three years after you got yourself out a
little bit that's it that's answer to
see yeah and I think with what I'm doing
right now is like is it is a fear of
scale a little bit because I'm doing so
I'm printing all
stuff myself you know I'm doing all the
printing my cell phone I also do like
designing and hand painting on clothing
pieces for musical artists like I got a
pair of pants steve aoki so the goal
really is is to kind of get into that
sphere of music and hip hop with like
custom pieces that I get it better I get
it and then it kind of like push the
brain that way yep yes I understand you
gotta you gotta figure out the three
things I told you do you need a partner
that can really drive the business or if
you don't because you have a lot of
pride and a belief in your business
savviness which you are showing in this
call you need to then jump now go full
throttle for 24 months and always feel
like you went for it or save every
[ __ ] penny you can pay off debt go
raw don't buy dot don't buy any [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] for 24 months and then jump
and do it that's your three options you
got one more thing real quick real quick
I'm trying to get jokes in the world can
we give a shout-out to the Instagram
yeah it's right here it's been up the
whole time there you go everybody follow
it thanks JC talk to me let's keep it
movin yugioh get a lot of love in the
comments yeah I mean I think oh there he
is sup bro there they are mr. oginski
could this to you AJ be way do you in
the buildin Greg you hear me good
morning guys good morning good morning
alright like I told a bunch of you on
social media we have a fairly big
announcement this morning it's been a
it's been a fun month for me obviously
last week the announcement of the sale
of empathy wines was a big deal and
today we are announcing with this
handsome young man you see on the screen
Greg in ski I think all of you know AJ
Vaynerchuk my delightful younger brother
we're announcing the expansion of Vayner
sports we've been in football for what
is five years now 84 and change four and
a half years on football so I'll let
I'll let you AJ and Greg kind of take
over the announcement and we'll I'm
pretty excited about it now as soon as
you turn out
and please share on social get the word
out
go ahead AJ and Greg cool I'll give it
this simple line and then Greg I'll let
you expand like Gary said we've been
football for the last four and half
years and this marks the moment in which
we expanded to baseball so we're fired
up Greg's gonna lead the charge and I'll
let him go into detail and Greg give a
little bit of a background of your
career we've partnered up with Greg and
creating Vayner baseball and invader
sports Greg a little context on you yeah
I'm you know a sports aficionado my
entire life I was a baseball player
wanted to do that that didn't work out
became a trial lawyer loved trying cases
but I was brought into the sports agent
world almost 20 years ago and so for 20
years I've been dedicated at
representing professional athletes and
really loving it you know loving it had
a lot of success had the privilege of
working for some really really great
athletes working with some really great
partners learning a lot and in starting
this new agency it was really the focus
for me to find the absolute best
partners available both on the client
side and with the company and I just got
to tell you guys I'm ecstatic that we're
able to come together and really enhance
this offering and I'm able to take my 20
years of perspective looking at this
business in determining what would be
the absolute best model to provide the
best representation of players and what
you guys have done on the business side
and the sports side coupled with what I
think myself and my very talented staff
bring to the table is really
unprecedented in the industry we're
gonna be able to do some some really
dynamic things for athletes and I
couldn't be more excited
AJ thoughts from your perspective yeah I
mean Greg hit it on the head I think
that we spent these last few years
proving out a different model
I think Boehner sports and and I think
what really linked us all together has
really driven home the idea that we
don't just represent athletes but we
represent human beings and athletes
today versus athletes even maybe when
Greg started his career have much more
of a focus on off the field and what
they're able to do with the platform
that the NFL or Major League Baseball
provides them
and so I think our success and our
unique background in terms of
entrepreneurship and best thing you know
Gary what you've done with your personal
brand that has a lot of guys gravitating
towards what we can offer and and I
think the other piece of it too Greg
I want you to go into more detail you're
being humble you know some of the work
that you've done and some of these
contracts that you've done they're legit
legit and so you know maybe just kind of
highlight a few of them yeah Greg if I'm
reading your wikipedia properly four
billion in contracts that you know
that's pretty [ __ ] serious [ __ ] yeah
we were we were very busy as an agency
we were very fortunate to have a lot of
really good clients and and I say that
it was a privilege and one thing I'm
very confident about is that myself my
staff Joe miz' Erica as and the other
agents that work with me Vernon Wells
now that he's an agent is every time by
the way quick fun fact on Vernon Wells
Vernon Wells was the backbone of two
fantasy championships for my brother AJ
here I hated Vernon Wells cuz AJ had him
at a cheap price in our fantasy me first
thing first thing I told Vernon when we
went Greg connected us was like hey man
you sent me two rings that was big I
appreciate it
and Greg Vernon was one of your
record-setting deals when he was your
client right yeah correct so we've had
the laser we've had the privilege of
left representing a lot of great players
at the important stage of their career
we've always delivered on the contract
side and Vernon Wells certainly is one
of those players with the record-setting
126 million dollar deal a revolutionary
player opted out at that time which
we've been duplicated in the Sabathia
deal and a few other deals so we've
always been extraordinarily focused as
we should on maximizing client
compensation setting new records not
just for our clients before the industry
as a whole so that the industry can grow
and we can continue to represent players
rights and maximize the competition and
Vernon Vernon has added it to his
Wikipedia page that he's one of the
stars you guys fantasy baseball team you
know from my perspective you know AJ and
I this is fun because we went into
football one way we've got a very small
shop we wanted to learn we didn't know
much about the sports representation
business AJ had a real passion decided
to leave vaynermedia wanted to get into
that world that was a really fun
execution and
we learned the pros and cons of going
that route and now we're kind of going
the other way I mean Gregg is keeping it
wildly humble but we have incredible
ambition for our Vater baseball practice
one we think baseball players are
grossly underrepresented off the field
in speaking in books in products and
services merchandise and definitely
social media endorsement and and
definitely investing AJ helped one of
our being our sports football players
Derek Morgan the Greek star from the
Tennessee Titans make a very smart
transition from instead of taking a
brand deal converting that into equity
and the company went public bringing
that kind of savviness to these baseball
players who don't have the level of
access that I think NBA players and
other celebrities have to get into angel
rounds you know I obviously had a great
incredible investing career but so did
AJ as we were navigating that and he got
into a lot of things early and smartly
and so that's number one number two you
know all of them all baseball players
are way less famous than they should be
you know when I think about the general
population of baseball of America excuse
me the demographics this country has an
incredible influx of Latin
spanish-speaking Americans and when you
think about the best you know South
America and Central America Mexico
DR Latin Spanish Americans playing
sports it's all baseball when you when
you look at Vlad and entities and Soto
and and by us the stars that lend or the
stars of baseball our spanish-speaking
baseball players in a country that is
emerging spanish-speaking at such a
level and yet there's so so much left on
the table and I believe much like we
looked at football I would argue
baseball even more than football is
falling short on off the field
opportunities for generational wealth
creation outside of the markedly large
contracts that baseball players get to
enjoy I think you know I would just to
me that excites me to no end and and I
think that's you know what's really cool
Gregg is that we basically are now with
this announcement in play for every
baseball player on earth because what
you've been able to do in your
incredible career enables every single
baseball player to feel confident that
they can get the contract done that they
need to get done with you at that helm
and then you know Maria I mean I've
watched everything from a rod to Jeter
to every single you know to Harper to
Trout you know there is no better entity
for off the field marketing and business
execution as of this second and Vayner
baseball in baseball and that includes
the top two or three firms that have
been around in this sport in perpetuity
and so that that excites me I think
we're gonna make substantial noise and
football was a marathon for AJ and I you
know we knew it was kind of a ten-year
play but I do think baseball is gonna
happen a little bit quicker with this
combo I think you're absolutely right
Gary it's gonna happen very quickly the
baseball the professional baseball
markets been very underserved when it
comes to the type of offering that
Vayner brings when it comes to educating
them on becoming business persons
becoming entrepreneurs to think that way
to market themselves to create a brand
and that's what it has attracted me to
come join Bader sports more than
anything is to really be honest and be
true about being able to affect great
change in great things for each
individual athlete that we represent and
knowing that we have that core
capability in-house is unbelievable
because after doing this for 20 years my
only ambition is to do the absolute best
shop to provide the absolute best
services and what I love about you guys
is you're right on the same page with me
I'm really good at my job and I do a
really good job but a fundamental aspect
of it is educating each client that I'm
working with so they develop as men in
some cases and get to a point of running
their own business they know how to do
it and yeah well the offer as opposed to
other agencies that maybe do a great job
for some superstar clients is we're
gonna bring that capability to every
client that we represent yeah I think
another aspect to you know in addition
to the three people talking through it
right now Mike Nelligan our EVP of
marketing and sales the one who actually
connected the three of us I think you
layer on the innovation
the multi-faceted approach that Gary and
I have the disruption gred you and your
teens track record of doing great work
on the business side and then Mike
having an extensive history 15 years or
so of the traditional and untraditional
endorsement sales marketing solutions I
think you just take those freak things
you just create this cocktail that's
perfect
absolutely right I've been I've been a
big fan of Mike neligan's work for a
long time we've talked for a long time
about how we can work together and now
bringing us all to hear we are all right
I'm gonna get back to my show big
announcement I'm really excited about it
boys ready to get to work look at it
look look look at a convert some of my
fantasy players on my team to actual
Vayner sports and so and now I'm gonna
buy a lot more baseball rookie cards so
excited Greg welcome to the family AJ
I'm really excited about this next
chapter for us love you bro woman thanks
guys everyone but I fight okay being a
baseball in the building Vayner sport's
calm if if you've got a nephew that's
crushing baseball and and we're really
excited about it all right I think I
think we can move on with the show
yeah what's up jack what up Gary how
many what I knew your Dan Marino bro
you're too young did you you didn't even
get to see him play did you he was a
beast I hate him but he was a beast
right gotcha
I'm in a Eugene Oregon I think you guys
that what's that brother I'm in Eugene
Oregon I love that I got that for yep I
did what's cooking by the way just
wanted to talk first about this I know
you talked about the Craigslist stuff
and I've been on that forever man like
seriously every morning to go to that
Craigslist read section that's probably
made like 7 grand selling like
ellipticals treadmills bench presses
like just yet dr. people put for free
I'm saying I you know I when I started
talking about that 23 years ago and I
was it was something I told friends to
do for the last 20 years like when you
have nothing when you have little and
you're willing to work and you have hard
work ethic in you the ability to like if
you're lucky enough to have a truck to
pick up heavy things that people want
for free it's yeah I see a bro that's
game over I mean that's in Christ
you know that's incredible good for you
what can I do for you I sold it for like
600 / it's like it's insane the kind of
stuff you'll see you encourage this what
can I answer for you bro yeah so I've
been going to college right now I'm
going to UVO study business because I'm
always I've always kind of been
interested in business but I just feel
like like the whole educational system
like it's just kind of bad like you know
we learned about billboard advertising
we learned about all sorts of things
that are super outdated and it's just
like something that just doesn't make
sense a plus like you know they're
taking school online now and go down
down and so just really makes sense to
me like to stay in school and I've
always like you know had aspirations to
like start a business or do something
like that but it's hard to get like
other people on board and seeing your
vision because you know I tell my family
like you know I don't want to really be
go to go to college right now and
they're all kind of like oh you know
you're lazy like you're too young like
you're not gonna be able to do it like
you know what do you what do you say to
the people of it kind of just like I
don't say anything best for you I don't
I don't say anything I lemon phrase I
say I love you and I know that you want
the best for me but I've got to live my
life and I'm gonna show you yeah just
get to work just get to work like I
don't I don't I don't have any interest
in convincing people what I'm up to
people think my whole life people
thought I was doing things wrong my
whole life yeah there was people who
that we just announced manor baseball
and people were like that's not gonna
work you know like my whole life that's
what people I don't care about talking
to people I care about showing people
you know bunch of my friend literally
when I launched empathy wines went up
when I launched empathy wines a lot of
my friends were like you're stretching
yourself too thin you go you've got too
much going on
you can't juggle all this and then boom
18 months later you know selling a
company for hefty eight figures like I'm
not I'm not worried about what people
are saying I'm worried about what I'm
doing yeah no it's true it's just it's
hard at times people like you know it's
not hard it's let me explain of course
it's hard but then you just it's like
turning a light switch you got to
understand your parents your uncle your
older brother your sister your aunt your
teacher your coach you got to understand
they're giving you advice that they
think is right they're not mean they're
not bad they love you they're trying to
show you love the problem is they're
coming from their perspective and their
perspective has nothing to do with your
life in New York it's like people like I
feel like everybody just wants the safe
option and like people want it's like no
you're like the ten year plan and
they're always asking me like Oh what's
your ten year plan and I'm like ten year
plan everyone's everyone's ten year plan
got completely [ __ ] in March it was
called Corona ten year plans there's not
that stupid and I hate that word but
like that's silly
ten years that's crazy to me bro live
your life stick it to them Dustin is
choppy now let's move on but Jack thank
you so much brother Jack's got it Jack
you gotta figure it out bro just live
your life listen here's the punchline
somebody's gonna be right if you think
you're so great and you can go do it
without college go do it and if you fail
maybe they were right but maybe also you
would have went to college you just got
into debt and wasting your time too and
you would have two losses and now you
got to go on your third one and your
third idea and guess what doing the
business that failed for five years
taught you a lot more than sitting in a
classroom we're learning about things
that happened ten years ago let's move
it
Tommen Tommen you're mute there we go
what's up what's good Tommen yeah um so
like how old are you where you from I'm
14 I'm from Easton love it what's good
so like two months ago I started a
digital media agents did you know
media marketing agency I was just
wondering what are you strategy to get
like your first client because I send
like 200 emails not a single reply but
in the title put I will do social media
for you for free of it okay also only my
question dude looked on I'm let's sit on
this for a second I know you're a smart
kid but like you you do understand that
when you're at 14 years old and and
you've got something new and you get
zero replies of 200 requests the number
one move is to get credibility so doing
that work for free for two or three
people for a month let's the next email
in six months say hi blank I did I did
or I do the social media for X Y & Z I'd
love to talk to you about your social
media boom you've got a totally
different conversation alright um I have
another question please
with you where are you thoughts on
dropshipping I'm a fan I think I think
over time you know what I love about
dropshipping is you can learn the
arbitrage of supply and demand and
making margin on something that you can
buy that somebody else wants to pay more
for use the infrastructure of Amazon to
do that for you oh it's a very tech it's
a very hardcore game it's not as easy as
it sounds but it's an incredible
learning process if somebody's not like
sports cards it's the same reason I like
garage saling same reason I like jack
going finding things on Craigslist for
free and then selling them anything that
teaches you how to buy something and
then resell it for more is always going
to be a skill that will stick with you
forever all right thank you
also one last question can I get a
follow you can brother yes where's your
account let's see here you can't Tommy
did you did you really grasp the free
thing cuz you went quick on it I just
you know I want to make sure you realize
how big of a deal that is all right it's
uh all right brother
I am your 430 first follower thank you
are you taking some pretty photos what
do you like you like the sky no I just
wanna be case
to Canada like a year ago good man you
need more content bro can you get your
game up all right you're welcome see ya
see it let's keep going hi I'm so
excited to be here first of all
congratulations oh sorry my dog is
flipping out here I got a I love the dog
make it more the treaty's no way
congratulations on Vayner sports and
other awesome things you're doing thank
you for providing this forum because
it's awesome and I'm so going away to be
in the presence of so many young awesome
people that if you are a young person
man this is the time I can't stress that
enough where everything is in your
favorite to do whatever you could
possibly want good news if you're 67
this is the time it's called the
internet internet is at its maturity the
cost of entry is extremely low and if
you're educated and willing to put in
the work an extraordinary amount of
opportunity sits in one's hand whether
you're 14 and 41 or or 91 well that's
really encouraging I feel like a baby in
my mind I'm still 27 although I've got
my 54th coming up here in a couple of
weeks you look amazing
Thanks lighting something that I've
never figured out everyone's like you
look horrible like I don't just light it
up and makeup and makeup so so here's
the deal I have been you know a Child
and Family Therapist for over 30 years
more than your folks today have been
breathing probably but love doing that I
focused on child welfare early childhood
issues social emotional issues autism
ADHD like the whole gamut mostly just
with young you know young kids and
parents and and so I ended up writing a
parenting book this is back in 2000 1999
2000
the Internet so that's why I'm so
excited about today because things are
are there back when I was doing this I
sold out of three printings of my book I
self-published all on my own just from
doing talks and settling back of the
room and I was doing all kinds of radio
but there was no way to deliver the book
I mean people would call it you know I
was trying to get the website thing
going it was $10,000 back then to get
order of alarm so I felt like I'm always
in the wrong time frame and now finally
the time is there so I was doing really
well I ended up doing nothing but my
public speaking signature talks them
ours and I've worked out on the the the
therapy so I got into of course real
estate which I love just investing and
also selling for other folks and
everything was like going top speed and
then I got into a five car pileup car
accident which led to finding out about
an ovarian tumor that I had and then
just to really top it off I got into a
really crappy marriage so all those
three things I enter my Moorea Moorea
it sounds like if I heard it right that
the car accident was a blessing because
you were able to get diagnosed earlier
oh yeah they I had zero symptoms and
even ultrasound didn't find it it was
only because of the MRI and I needed to
have from the accent for my back
otherwise even if I had symptoms I'd be
dead right now they they would not have
detected it's a very great help or not
and anyway so the turnaround I think
it's kind of like for me what happened
was you know what's that saying like
everybody has a plan and so you get
punched in the face and boy that felt
like a punch in the face and it took me
a long time I started like really
questioning like what am i doing maybe I
don't know what I'm doing you know all
this stuff so I started getting
Jing and that led me down the like
rabbit hole of different people telling
me what I should do apparently saying
there's no money in that there's you
this go corporate be lists and I felt
like I really lost my identity and all
of that so my one issue is just overload
of opinions and input from all over the
place do this funnel know change the
name of your stuff it's too negative
it's all it's all it's all that whole
world of Mark internet marketers funnels
conversion transactional it's a very
short term it's it's money over
everything
yes I understand it's it's a world that
I think has a lot of shortcomings yeah
so it feels really inauthentic to me and
so I'm like alright I don't want to be
that cheesy you know oh I'm by my
program or you know whatever but I do
have a wealth of knowledge I am you know
the real deal I can honestly tell you
when it comes to kids stuff nobody so so
are we talking about how do we think
about a business model yeah yeah so I
mean that has been it is like really
focusing the messaging or or should I
know what are you trying to sell I'm not
trying to solve anything right now but
what will you try to sell because I
think the strategy has to be based like
do for example do you run it do you do
you want to do one-on-one therapy and
consulting or strategy sessions and for
example if one wants to do that you know
I mean every day of my life I get an
email or DM where people are offering me
levels of money for just an hour of my
time that blows my mind that's because I
took the route of giving unlimited good
content for free for a decade for free
which became the way that I could have
people wanting to pay me $25,000 for now
or consulting I don't want to do that
I don't do that so that's that other
people want to do a hundred people in a
group and charge them a hundred dollars
a month other people don't want to
charge anything they just want to do
speak
and selling books because they are like
there's a million different ways to
something the question becomes which one
do you want what do you feel most
authentic about is the real question for
me it's the speaking and and even taking
it online doing online seminars doing
things lies and then you need to put out
unlimited content for free across the
ten platforms that matter Facebook and
Scrimm you know LinkedIn twitch tik-tok
podcast YouTube you know on and on and
on and you need to do it at the highest
level every day so that you build up
demand so stuff comes to you okay gotcha
Maria whoever is asking has given up the
leverage okay let me explain that yeah
if you're putting out incredible content
every day every day then people are
gonna come to you
gotcha if you're out there trying to
figure out how to like not bring a whole
like try and if you're out there trying
to figure out how do you get to a place
where you are getting paid to speak then
then a lot of times you end up being the
person asking hey can I speak at your
conference hey you know how do I get in
there at you're asking me hey can you
introduce me to the people that you just
feel you're asking right my strategy has
been if I put out the best information
in the world for free and perpetuity
things will come to me and and that's
how it worked I get it I just because of
my confusion
I stopped posting you know I have things
on it your uncle who's down good news
rung up yes yes uncle I you know for if
you listen to somebody who said you know
no you can't put it out for free then
nobody's gonna pay you for it
good news I'm confused I do not agree
with that yeah no no but I could be I
could be wrong but I can tell you right
now if you're the real deal then you
need to be putting it out for free and
let it come to you the more the real
deal you are
the more that needs to be the strategy
okay yeah I did I did a thing of lives
like the 12 days of creare before all
this kovat stuff counting down to
Christmas and I got like a really
awesome response to that and then I was
told while you're going in a different
direction right so I think it needs to
be yeah yeah thing I don't I don't like
I don't everything I've heard from you
whoever this business coaches that
you're paying that's giving you [ __ ]
advice I'm done we need to be done with
that okay just do the do just give the
doo boo okay
listen to me yes karma doing the right
thing like me who lead truly wanting to
help is always the best business
strategy I love that and that that's
where I was that's where I had started
and that it got all convoluted like I
say afterwards cuz I say right now I get
it I get it you got into a mucky spot
you started doubting all of a sudden
short-term wins were needed maybe money
was needed the middle makes sense to me
I respect your [ __ ] out of how you got
there uh good news we're still young as
[ __ ] don't let that [ __ ]
fourteen-year-old throw you off you know
what I might love that 14-yard comment
to Eric I love them I love Tom and too
but don't let that age throw you off you
still have literally minimum ly thirty
years of real execution in front of you
maybe at 84 I'm okay with you going and
chillin and so 30 years 30 years I'd
have a long [ __ ] future in front of
you start doing what comes natural to
you the other stuff didn't come natural
to you which is why it didn't work
exactly and I thought yeah it's not
working but yeah I'm hooking up with
Tommen and I will pay you all right oh
there we go yeah all right talk to you
thank you so much on the rack make sure
you clarify hooking up with Tommen
that's a that's a different kind of
tournament I thought the same thing
we're just idiots all right let's keep
it going
Oh John see what's good
tell Gary how are you I'm well in you
I'm doing so well today's gonna get
straight to the point
for a lot of years it wasn't that great
at school in middle school I was in the
decelerated landing program and in high
school in college I kind of stuck it to
my parents and I worked really really
hard I buckled down I've gone straight
A's all throughout I've taken still made
classes that I'm 19 right now I'm
actually gonna graduate in the spring
just because I've taken on such a
workload and throughout that process
why'd you do that
go ahead through out that process well
if you want that process I was really
set on being a doctor and I was really
excited about it and it was because I
kind of had an interest in psychology
and I was like my parents when they're
like oh you should be a doctor and be a
psychiatrist because that'll make more
money and so like once that seed was
planted it kind of grew into a force I
was like I'll go to med school and after
freshman year I was like I don't do that
anymore and I have stuck with my psych
major but I've been less and less sure
about it as I've gone through college
and with all Corona happening and
classes being online I was thinking
about taking a semester off starting a
business and maybe even trying to drop
out but what my college did is they
shortened the requirement for how many
semesters you had to stay a la colleges
you actually just stay eight semesters
like you're not about to graduate early
my college led us so I'm just gonna
finish my degree and I started business
this summer and I'm kinda having a hard
time getting away from oh I got a is
this quarter or A's this semester like
that's great I did a good job I can see
it to something more intangible like how
I judge myself and where she said that I
love this question
I think he should judge yourself based
on how happy you are on a daily basis
okay
stick with me here yeah the number one
thing I don't like about school
is the short-term gratification of a
tangible subjective often result that
reinforces stay in the lane behavior
mm-hmm meanwhile your subconscious and
your [ __ ] soul has been quietly
chipping away at your conscious over the
last sounds like 12 to 18 months helping
you realize I don't like this yeah
you're very fortunate you're in an
extremely young age for that to become
something that you're aware of then you
follow it up with such a thoughtful
[ __ ] question I'm proud of you bro
that was such a great question thank you
unfortunately people go from grades
ABCDF to you no diploma to salary
starting point to promotion and title
and like everybody just stays in this
[ __ ] game and to your point everybody
judges themselves tangibly how many
followers do I have how many what grades
that you know how many how much money do
I make
what car do I have versus like and it's
all [ __ ] sucks meanwhile if you judge
yourself of like is today good is this
week good is this monthly because could
today could be bad when people get
caught on the way I think about the
world is they decide one day sometimes I
go three weeks and it's not phenomenal
but in the net of a year of a half a
decade it is phenomenal so people over
judge the micro under judge the macro
but need to judge it in the framework of
happiness and fulfillment not outside
affirmation contra I don't do tea with
Gary Vee for the followers or the views
or the things that nature I do it
because it feels nice to help people I'm
pumped what Tommen and Maria are feeling
right now yeah it's the easiest thing to
judge in a world brother judge how you
[ __ ] feel okay
and I feel like I know the answer to
this question but when you say that and
when you're thinking about what you want
to do how you want to spend your time
how much of a percentage doesn't money
take up because when I leave college
there's a part of me that really wants
to be independent like good absinth luck
it ebbs and flows you know I think you
know the money's never been a big one
for me mainly because I had the ability
to live humbly doctrine um
I mean dude I'm not a fan of money I
don't know what else to say like I'm
good at making it which I don't I don't
I don't underestimate the the gift that
is money-making but I'm not into it as
much as people may think you know they
hear things like I want to buy the Jets
and they associate that with money I
it's just my relationship with money is
very strange I love the fact that
they're you know I like the ability to
do I like the ability to recognize that
my talent mixed with hard work created
some variable of that execution but like
I don't know me like I'm even mustering
I'm even struggling to get hyped on
money right now to balance out this
convo because I'm being empathetic and
compassion and sympathetic to
individuals who aren't good at making it
need it are struggling so I don't want
to be glib but but it's not about how
much you make it's about how much you
spend like if you get out of college and
you live with your four most ambitious
to be happy friends in a shitty [ __ ]
neighborhood in a garbage apartment you
know very quickly you don't just don't
need that much yeah yeah you know like I
mean I mean you know so for me you know
for everybody it's different but for me
I take for granted my ability to make it
thus I don't respect it as much as other
people I work hard I'm proud of it but
like I want to be happy more than like
but like but it's a funny thing right
because it's a scoring mechanism like so
for example like when I'm like on eBay
last night for like five hours trying to
figure out which sports cards are under
price to buy it is under the context of
like I'm gonna buy this Kareem
abdul-jabbar rookie card for 2000 it's
gonna be worth four thousand in a year
it's not about the two thousand dollar
profit it's about the smarts of seeing
it yeah yeah that's what makes it fun
for me okay
okay I get that so it's like it's less
about the actual money that you're
making but the way in which like you're
using different tactics and strategies
them and it's like like you say a lot of
time it it is a game and it's a game you
know I love being an entrepreneur I
don't want to diss on money or
entrepreneurship or capitalism it's it's
just the money parts not the part that
gets me going I don't like looking at my
money or having it or saying how much I
have it I don't give a [ __ ] about that I
like the game of collect up getting it
through something smart or something
Noble or something hardworking or
betting on something for 10 years and
then you know it's business I like
business like a business deal I like the
business of it gotcha gotcha all right
Kay that's all I had thank you so much
for hang on John you're super super
thoughtful kid listen to me judge
yourself on how good it feels okay
you're gonna you're gonna have a very
difficult time in one transition you
were not this good student and the
system your parents the school system
they told you you couldn't you took that
you put that chip on your shoulder and
you [ __ ] it stuck it to them even the
way that you delivered the sentence of
showing your parents you took the energy
of you can't and you said [ __ ] you I'll
show you and that was your driver yeah
yeah I like that because I have a very
I'm a very chippy [ __ ] however what I
had layered on that was I was chip
but I was willing to play a game where
there was no obvious miss to me winning
and then it was a surprise at the end
you went through a game where it was at
you know it was affirmation every 90
days yeah I'm trying to figure out how
to story tell this to you so that you
get out of that because if you can
convert it to the energy don't worry
about what everybody's saying along the
way you're just gonna be like tada look
at me at 30 I'm happy and I'm fruitful
can I look at me at 40 I'm happy and I'm
truthful tada you know so so try to
figure out how you can still play that
game that clearly works for you but
don't need and in fact how do you get
comfortable with it being the other way
I actually seek out subconsciously
people to not believe in me hmm I don't
want the affirmation I want to be the
underdog I want to be one of the work
one of the things that's going on with
me is this whole garyvee thing is a
problem for me because now you know resi
sold for a lot of money k-swiss sold for
a lot of money and with you so for a lot
of money like people starting to realize
I'm not a motivational speaker I'm a
[ __ ] business
[ __ ] juggernaut and the more they
believe that the more everything I do
now gets received with that's gonna work
instead of what I want which is this is
not gonna work
yeah yeah I think that it's difficult
just because you know it's really good
for me it's have that tangible like eh
eh eh but it's also like I can show it
to enhance and I can't stick it to them
that way it's hard to stick it to your
parents not that's the goal but when I'm
just like okay I'm happy you know and I
that's where you're not seeing it yeah
let me promise you the number one
sticking it to people move in the world
is saying you're happy cuz ninety nine
percent are yeah contra they may not
react the same way as an A but I promise
you when you go back to your car and you
drive back to your friends and get a
nice Sunday afternoon with them when
your mom or dad's in the shower thinking
they're like first we're gonna be happy
cuz they love you but if there's really
some friction there or like some little
chip eNOS I promise you right now the
number one way to win this whole [ __ ]
thing bro I know unlimited
miserable [ __ ] millionaires unlimited I
know more miserable as clock
millionaires than I know [ __ ] happy
millionaires
dan and bro damn is right because if you
previously if people actually understood
what unhappiness was it doesn't matter
you know when you're doing [ __ ]
unlimited [ __ ] prescription drugs in
your [ __ ] mansion you're not a happy
[ __ ] person when you're [ __ ]
drinking a bottle of [ __ ] alcohol
every night to two o'clock in the
morning in your [ __ ] Maserati you're
not a [ __ ] happy person people need
to wake the [ __ ] up yeah yeah winning
100 percent 100 percent yeah bro you can
show the promise you happiness is
exactly how you chip it I'm excited too
good I'm excited for you I really
believe in you bro I've intuitively
really believe in you that's why I'm
keeping you out here I think you can
really do this but I want you to
challenge yourself to get more
comfortable with long term gray vs.
short term black and white yeah I think
that's really really hard because I've
been kind of put out content for my
small business like also send a bunch of
emails out every night it's hard to
balance my time between like building up
a lot of content and putting up good
information writing a little blog and
post it on Instagram doing all these
things that it's really hard to see the
return on investment you know I think
all things that are great are hard yeah
yeah yeah it's just tough because like I
everything's everything greatest stuff
yeah everybody wants a 1% life and
nobody wants to put in the 1% work ethic
and mental strength and patience
required to get there yeah
yeah I watch the world and everyone's
like I want I'm like that's nice
everybody wants seven point seven
billion people want mm-hmm yeah it's
just so difficult because again in
school and like again I don't want to be
like a victim here and be like Oh school
ruined me or whatever it is but it
really is a truth that the world you
took right you holding ruin you you
yourself if you believe that because you
chose that was the outlet to stick it to
people yeah I chose a different outlet
yeah I didn't double down on school and
apply myself I said oh you think I'm
[ __ ] watch this I'm gonna completely
check out get F's my whole life
whoo my skill on something I love and
then be a [ __ ] savant in your [ __ ]
mouth and now they [ __ ] want to put
statues and my [ __ ] high school of me
a kid that they wanted to keep the [ __ ]
out of there I mean how did you even
deal with something like that like
having so many people I enjoy I enjoy
when people think I say I love my haters
on social media yeah I mean you talk
about that all the time about it's the
truth I mean I don't know if people
think I'm out here for show I [ __ ]
love it let me get this straight
you took the time to watch my video I
don't even know who you are I don't know
who you are I have no time to figure
that out I'm here to like bring love not
hate you decided to obsess over what I'm
doing and then you decided to leave
negativity and you're trying to bring me
into negative negativity loves company
misery loves company like you I love it
because it's had the chip to my shoulder
I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] stick it to
your face come on man I feel so much
sympathy and compassion for you I feel
so bad that you live a life that behind
a keyboard and an anonymous name often
with a private account you've decided to
spit hey my god you must be in a very
bad place I love you I'm so sorry that
you're living this life yeah and I'm
sorry that my light of positivity and
optimism and happiness is something that
you're so subconsciously jealous of that
you need to try to drag it down to even
make it palpable yeah it's all about
balancing that grizzly bear with that
cuddly teddy bear inside of you yeah I
like that I like that I like that
analogy I I I have that I'm a [ __ ]
assassin I will kill everyone I love
everybody and I have that I have that I
have nothing but love unlimited always
give trust first nothing has to be
earned with me who the [ __ ] am i I love
you I
you I love you you want to go into a
dark place with me I'm ready to [ __ ]
throw it out
[ __ ] you yeah you know and I've totally
found that I promoted one of my tic toc
videos I post on Instagram I promote it
because I like people for that like
those videos and the only cons I got
were people like oh like no one can
understand what you're saying we're like
like this doesn't make sense like your
Facebook like this information like it's
not good and here's why I build a little
blah and like those are the only
comments on it dude that sounds like a
successful day for me there I mean I
mean it but no people see me now
everything I did in the wine world with
you should see my youtube videos at
first the entire wine industry thought
it was stupid I lost my mind social
media it's a fad you've got this big
wine business what are you [ __ ]
around with Twitter for pero bro do you
know how much how many whispers behind
my back two years ago all my friends
were making about this obsession with
sports cards and it's so stupid it's a
waste of my time that market has
outperformed in stock market in real
estate market substantially yes I like
the booze I live for the [ __ ] booze i
I I am devastated for my haters if they
actually knew if they actually knew that
their hate was my fuel they'd be if they
knew the chemicals in my body they'd be
devastated absolutely devastated they'd
be devastated
by knowing how much love I have for them
compassion deep sympathy empathy deep
slash complete need for their hisses and
boos because it fuels me to [ __ ]
stick it to them at scale they would've
crushed crushed John I love it I love
you talk to you bro see you later guys
let's wrap this up today's the one-year
anniversary of wine texts by the way
that was fire let's get that clipped up
today we have our one-year anniversary
wine it is pretty
workable it is one of the best wines
Weaver offered it's a 97 out of 100
points quart of wine from Europe that we
are gonna sell for under $20 a bottle
literally literally every single person
that's watching right now that literally
every single percents watching right now
that buys wine in any shape or form
should absolutely sign up and pick up 12
of today's please share wine text com2
every single procedure with line today's
is the day yep under $20 a bottle yep
under 20 today's gonna be wild that was
a hard transition Justin from that
emotional monster to like hey we
interrupt this program for a wine
effects commercial
yeah but Gustin you need to buy a bottle
today alrighty yep get re activated cuz
I'm sure you wanna subscribe because
your jerk no you do not sign up the wine
text if you don't buy why cuz cost money
to set a textbook good show that was a
good one at the end there was some real
deep [ __ ] there yeah we are not back
tomorrow because now I have an issue so
we'll figure it out we'll let everybody
know on social and we're back hope you
enjoyed today's show or not can you also
do the thing that Sid asked for at the
end you know how I used to do askgaryvee
you know we insure the podcast or
whatever what's that number how you and
at the end of like kind of give like a
wrap up on askgaryvee of like what the
episodes hello on this episode got it is
this for the podcast I think and I'm
gonna find out about that I didn't I saw
your tweet you know the problems with
the audio of level isn't oh yeah yeah
okay um on this episode of tea with Gary
Vee we talked to a 14 year old starting
a business a 54 year old who's gonna
switch it back up and we get really deep
into the relationship with haters and
how to measure the gray instead of the
short-term black and white good perfect
awesome alright everybody have a great
day hit me up on Twitter my text I'm
telling you big one today